we've done lots of puzzles in our
somewhat advanced group right we touched
many many different ideas for
intermediate moves to back rank two pins
two forks to discover checker which we
discovered through a toddy discovered
threads little bit many many ideas in a
wheel game we have all those ideas
somehow mixed like nobody is holding a
sign saying okay now choose idea one two
and five and that's how you build your
combination we have to take everything
in consideration and density in many
times positions can be very very similar
with some one tiny different that makes
a combination possible or impossible
let's first of all start with this
position white is to play I will wait a
minute to minute and see well what
should what be planking what would you
play it about okay and if the rule
captures so what what idea would that be
discovered right yeah uncover but in
winning right okay perfect
Charlie was this your idea as well okay
excellent now what about this position
what should I play here
should I play the same way win the quick
now why no excellent job very good and
you know this is something really really
important about just the ability to
visualize the position several moves
from now
so what Isabel basically saying is that
capture capture capture all those are
really forcing in black hairs
checkmate on the back ranked positions
is almost almost the same but well not
really working right tiny difference the
pawn on h3 is no longer on h3 okay now
what about this position do already
nobody so look when the pawn was on III
it was checkmate but right now the pawn
moved right tiny tiny differences and
white is actually winning pawn endgame
extra pawn right so what is actually
going to be winning this position which
is extra pawn white is to play
any Mohan's
yes
Quincy - and what are you going to win
with Quincy - a bishop
okay the king is under a check and the
bishop right white is to play here let
me maximize it whites to play yes very
similar to the idea before right only
that instead of going to g2 you go to b7
and the king is under check and you're
gonna win the bishop this way right
so it's basically what's the difference
between those positions there are very
similar ideas with tiny differences but
the idea is very much the same for
example I can take this bishop put the
bishop over here what would white be
playing now yes excellent job exactly
the same thing we will find a way to
attack the bishop and the king by the
way this is something quite important
for games that you are playing
whenever you play a game and you see
pieces that are undefended in a long
time longer pieces that are undefended
or big targets - what a double attack a
discovered check is some kind some sort
of some skewer that finds several pieces
not defended
I mean having pieces that are undefended
for too long many time is going to cause
some material to some players just
something important to remember okay
white is to play here
I'll let you answer but just one more
minute okay you will enter
what's our idea Knight to g5 okay
what's your idea oh no no no there you
are raising your hand before right
Knight to f6 you mean
Knight to f6 okay so we have 95 96 yes
Adi okay okay
okay we'll take it seven yes we'll take
it seven
pawn to b3 but wipe on to b3 I mean you
can just but you can just take your
Bishop immediately okay so let's start
with the moles so I understand Knight g5
he's attacking the Queen and attacking
the 87 pawn right but what should black
play after Knight g5 check and take the
knight why not go into default check and
take the knife so it's a better move
right you want to get you want to play
the most straightforward line not to
allow many different possibilities okay
so this was one thing Knight g5 was
suggested then Knight f6 is actually not
a bad move Knight f6 black is going to
play what white is threatening checkmate
that's no joke actually checkmate is a
serious threat black will play heal
white will take take ok black is white
is a bit better because he has a
somewhat extra pawn I mean the pawns are
equal but those are not very pretty but
probably very reasonable chances to make
a draw here okay now what about this
move that was suggested by few of you
Black has two possibilities
let's start first possibility what is
the most logical movie of all black to
start considering yes
take the look no of course that the
first move you have to consider and what
is right going to play yes Knight to g5
and win the Queen and white is going to
be a piece up a piece up for white same
position as before only this white has a
knight so this is going to lose the
Queen so you have to think about the
other alternative what happens after
King to g8 yes what which move white
will play here 90 move to g5 but once
again remember before black will play
check and take yes
that's a bit better now
well what the actual play here what an
actual play here the Kings in check so
what should we play - well
laughs eight and not about this one
yes Isabel
the king is in checkmate Knight of 6 is
checkmate right the king is in check the
Luke is protected the King cannot go to
the seventh rank because of their walk
and you cannot go to f8 because of the
bishop so so Luke take it seven is
either either checkmate in one move all
winning a piece basically giving the
rock for the Queen and white is the
pizza right okay
so this this was this forcing enough the
way I see it it was forcing enough okay
now similar position somewhat similar
position but tiny different I take this
ball and put it here almost identical
look I just change one pawn in the
position there was a pawn on 87 and I
just moved it to g7
yes okay what would black play uh-huh
and what what perfect perfect perfect
perfect
nothing to say believe me the less that
I speak it means the day move that you
have suggested is perfect
check one move King eight 795 check King
go somewhere right it's straightforward
as possible now maybe what will be
stronger than such continuation only if
you have checkmate in one or two moves
or team I don't see any checkmate so no
no point in starting to say oh no you
know you just win the Queen
straightforward if they leave the
checkmate well Bravo there is a
checkmate but there isn't all right well
what about let's change the position
once again when I was actually very very
nice to you at the beginning because I
was helping you a bit what about this
position white is to play here this is
tricky
you know Oh No yes 96 and what's your
idea with 96
to move to where Knight to f6 and black
will move to g8 that wasn't yes what
so what is the threat Isabel do you
agree
the threat is locate seven how can black
prevent work eight seven
yes but can like Vivendi small not
really I mean okay to be to be precise
blabla should click oMG fall and then
he's gonna lose the queen for a night
but he's not getting checkmate what was
the difference why was it crucial why
was it crucial to put the pawn here
because if you remember in the very
first position that I showed you black
had a defense to the idea of 96 day
defense was what is black gonna play
here yes 25 one different square for
porn makes the position really really
really different right okay let's look
at those types of positions let's look
at this position why oh yes white is to
play okay this is pretty straightforward
right
what shall we play Queen 287 checkmate
right I agree now let's we're gonna do
it really slowly now let's say this is
the position what should we play yes
Queen each one King g8 so basically you
only needed to see one move right Queen
h1 because you already had a position
before in your head yes charlie Queen h5
right yeah but okay Queenie try but it's
same idea
alright now what about this position
white is to play
yes very good
the king will capture exactly so
basically this is this is one of the
most important ideas in chess with what
we are doing now basically we understand
the pattern and then we understand how
to get to it right it's pattern
recognition something incredibly
important not just interesting chess but
we'll speak about chess now it basically
tells us that we don't need to study
everything from the very start we know
something right for example I'll give
you my brilliant thinking if you know
how much four plus four is okay it's
eight right eight excellent job okay and
so if I ask you how much 24 plus 24 all
you need to know is 20 plus 20 is 40 you
already know that four plus four is
eight so it's about 48 right 48 a bit
higher you see it's exactly the same
thing we have already some knowledge so
we know something like let's say you are
driving think about it and you know how
to get from one point to another okay
from point A to point B you know how to
get but now you are in point C okay and
you don't know how to get to point A but
you know how to get to point B okay so
you might know the way all you know
right because you know how to get there
and you already know that that's exactly
what we are doing here why is it kind of
easy you all understood oh the Queen
will checkmate on 87 we need to get the
King so look at that
no no need to waste time we can put this
funny position but it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter I know the idea right
I'll play this move and this move and
this move in this move right but I just
know what I want to get in this move
and I could put like well
no hopefully you don't have a mouse
sleep right
and now checkmate
so
so this is tiny bit our idea of pattern
recognition right okay it's black to
move here first of all we will switch
turn the board so next to plain black
has tiny bit trouble here maybe not tiny
bit no no no black black is a very
specific problem black has a very very
specific problem okay let me put white
key in here what what is black only play
here what what's blacks problem here yes
just the Queen's okay so move the Queen
what's the problem move the Queen but
it's just the Queen being threatened so
what else they broken the Queen are
being threatened right so black is
basically under double attack the Queen
and the rook are under attack that is
your problem non diff the Queen's under
attack okay just move the Queen and now
if you're just going to move the Queen
the bishop will take the rook rook is
five points Bishop three kind of not so
cool for black so this is why Queen d6
was what type of move in this position
an intermediate one it's a check for
signals doesn't matter what white is
going to play here move the rook and
saved the material okay well let's get
kinda same position and see if we can
have other ideas let's look at this
position and black to play
what will we play Queen b5 and why would
we play Queen b5 so an intermediate hoop
is going to be what check captures and
creating threat right big threat so the
way to save actually black stroke is by
attacking the right hook
yes okay
Quincy six but it's not a bad idea not
in a second we'll see that it's not bad
idea
but what happen if I will take the rook
no no I'll take the rook the Queen will
take the Queen but the bishop is exactly
now let's let's make it this way you
know here let's change the position tiny
bit make I mean that but right idea
principally let's say this is the
position and black to play here this is
the position and now it is black to play
yes look to c6 okay that's a move which
other move do we have
I want to another move yes but going to
d6 I'll just take the rook no Bishop
will take the rook and you're kind of
down material yes charlie
Quincy six okay so we have Luke c6 a
move and Quincy six now dramatic but
just one of those is really correct and
the other one is kind of not so which
one is correct works is sick so Quincy
sticks and why it's not a coin flip and
you know we choose which one is correct
Quincy sticks or walk sistex will see
six of realistics yes you think it
Quincy stood there to put the Queen
yes so okay and you can no perfect and
perfect very very good and you should
have said like just if we want to speak
chest language you would have said
instead of Bishop would go down and take
the night you take Bishop takes d8 or
Bishop capture night right but perfect
very very good basically what's your
name Elijah
what is Elijah just said look basically
followed what we have been screaming
here for almost three months right
captures captures captures no other way
to think if work c6 capture capture
capture black is a white is upper piece
that's it if there was no night there
Queen six o'clock sistex might not have
made any difference
the last capture is the key very very
good and that's why Charlie was this
what you were thinking also yes that the
night is going to be hanging here for
example the Queen c6 is perfect because
after take the rook is going to get out
off threat and capture back if the
knight was on f8 then I don't see any
difference between walk c6 I mean okay
we can discuss which movies which movies
better is it Queen c6o book c6 but it
will be from completely crazy six it's
better movie but there is nothing to
capture after it now those positions are
positions form kind of real normal
positions nobody is holding a sign
saying checkmate in one move or capture
and those are quite advanced positions I
mean we kind of built it in the last
many months we're gonna have even tiny
bit
all complicated position next class but
we have all elements in them whether it
is intermediate move whether it is
discover check whether it is threatening
checkmate so today we had basically most
of our class was somewhat I would say
the pattern recognition of small
differences forcing moves right Elijah
was saying the white internationally
just followed capture capture capture
right wing